[Music]
so as you all probably know Marvel
Studios is celebrating its 10th year
anniversary and celebrating that they
have launched an interactive website
that actually has some pretty cool stuff
on it but over the weekend that website
released 33 brand new character posters
and I must say I think they're pretty
awesome I'll put the link to the website
in description below and of course I'll
briefly go over each poster now there's
really not too much to look into with
these posters I don't think they
particularly mean anything it's just a
celebration of the 10th anniversary from
Marvel Studios they're really just
visually appealing and they really are
they're giving praise and glory to our
favorite characters that we've come to
love over the years which they should I
do however think there is something to
be said about the characters they chose
to put on these posters I think it says
something about the future of the MCU
and we'll talk about that after we go
through each one will start with Ironman
because well he started it all if you
look to the bottom right it says more
than a and then the a is the Avenger
symbol of course suit and each poster
will say more than a and describe
something about the character which i
think is really awesome in an Iron Man's
case it's more than a suit big man in a
suit of armor take that off what are you
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist I love a suit in the same
because it's decked out in gold and
obviously that's sort of the theme of
these posters as the gold and his suit
looks awesome again he started it all
and has appeared in nine films and of
course following him is Captain America
more than a shield and he certainly is
he's heroic he's brave he's good ol
Cappy he's appeared in eight films and
here's hoping that he survives the ninth
Avengers for next is the Scarlet Witch
more than a tragic past and she
certainly is she has become one of the
most powerful characters in the MCU
and I'm so glad we finally saw her
envision together on screen next is
Black Widow back with her red hair which
I love and she is apparently getting her
own solo film didn't we have ant-man
more than a thief which is funny to
think about that an MCU that's how
ant-man started Hank Pym needed a thief
I really love this poster because I love
how it shows him shrinking down with the
bigger shadows in the back going down to
ant-man the size of an ant and ant-man
and the wasp comes out in just a few
weeks black panther more than a king I
really like the colors in this I really
really like the purple and I really like
the wakandan letters all over the suit I
think this was a very well done poster
it's too bad he got turned to ash at the
end of infinity war but I have a feeling
we'll see him again before the end of
Avengers 4 the Winter Soldier more than
a mission his character has really
developed and really grown on me in the
MCU throughout time and it appears now
that he'll be taking on the mantle of
the White Wolf
next is Drax the destroyer his story in
the MCU is a little different than it is
in the comics but we've certainly come
to know him better through his comedic
relief throughout the films and through
his pain and suffering of losing his
family Doctor Strange more than a doctor
Doctor Strange is one of my favorite
characters in the comics and in the MCU
and I think he's gonna play a critical
part in a vendor's for Falcon more than
a wingman he very well might take on the
role of Captain America after Avengers 4
Nick Fury more than a spy and of course
he's more than a spy he put together the
Avengers the first time and he called
Captain Marvel at the end of infinity
war thanks Nick Gamora more than a
weapon we've all grown to love Gamora
and she has such a tragic backstory the
adopted daughter of Thanos Thanos racer
and then an infinity war he killed her
but I also think that she will have a
very important part in
vengers for Groot I am Groot I am Groot
Hawkeye more than a marksman that's
right he's gonna be picking up some
swords as Ronan in Avengers 4 Heimdall
more than a watchful eye I think he'll
probably be making an appearance in
Avengers 4 as well the Hulk
more than a temper I actually think
we're gonna need to see a little bit
more of that temper in Avengers 4 so the
Hulk can pop out Loki more than a
trickster we all love Loki even though
he's the god of mischief and betrays
Thor over and over again we love him I
mean look at that smirk how can you not
love him you can tell he's up to no good
mantas more than a sensation remember
her antennas are not for detecting
doorways I say that if you are about to
go through a doorway there's too little
your antenna will feel this and if it's
anything other than you specifically not
being decapitated by a doorway I win no
not for feeling doorway Oh
Nakia more than a warrior apparently she
was on a special mission during the
events of infinity war so maybe we'll
see her in Avengers 4 or black panther 2
nebula more than a machine and I think
that we really did see that she's a lot
more than a machine in infinity war we
saw her suffer from Thanos as torture
and from losing her sister Gamora I'm
curious to see her role in Avengers 4
because in the comics she actually ends
up wielding the Infinity Gauntlet so I
guess we'll have to wait and see next is
a coy more than a bodyguard and with her
King gone it seems like she's gonna have
to really step up herself and almost
become an Avenger in Avengers 4 and then
of course Shuri more than a genius
she is more than likely going to take on
the Black Panther mantle since her
brother and king of Wakanda has been
turned to ash due to thanasis snap at
least until they figure out a way to
bring him back
spider-man more than a kid Oh Spidey
I'll just say I don't want to go
star-lord
more than a legendary outlaw yeah yes
he's the
that punched a nose in the face and kept
the Avengers from getting the Infinity
Gauntlet just kidding but seriously long
more than a librarian I am assuming that
he's going to have a much bigger role
and Avengers force since Doctor Strange
has been wiped from existence vision
more than a mind I actually think that
they're going to be bringing vision back
in Avengers for it not due to time
travel or anything like that but I think
Sheree will find a way to bring him back
war machine more than a fighter I really
hope he gets some nanotech from Tony
Stark and Avengers 4 he's certainly
going to need it he did drop some huge
bombs in infinity war though I'm like
boom you looking for this the wasp more
than a partner yes he is judging by the
trailers for ant-man and the wasp she
could probably kick a man's butt so I'm
excited to see the movie Valkyrie more
than a sword I do not think we've seen
the last of Valkyrie in the MCU
especially since they're probably doing
more Thor movies at least we all hope so
and I think we'll probably see her in
Avengers 4 at some point Thor more than
a god yeah he was he was the best part
about Avengers infinity war to me from
when the Guardians found him and his
humor when he was on their ship to where
he went to neduvaali R with rocket and
team Groot and forged Stormbreaker and
when he showed up to Wakanda like a boss
that was that was the best scene rocket
on a shoulder it was awesome and then
taking Stormbreaker and just destroying
everything all of the ships and then
throwing it right into Thea noses chest
of course if he would have hit him in
the head he probably would have killed
him and therefore would have kept half
of the universe from being wiped out of
existence but you know we all want to
see in Avengers 4 movie
[Music]
my second favorite poster out of all of
them is trash panda just kidding Rocket
Raccoon more than a trash panda I think
one of the saddest scenes and infinity
war was not spider-man but we're rocket
had to watch teen Groot disappear Groot
was basically rocket son and this was
pretty much confirmed when the rooster
brothers came out and said that groots
last words were dad and the poster
coming in for the win is gorg
more than a friend of Doug's and I love
that that's his caption more than a
friend of Doug's and it's really funny
how that's like a perfect description of
his character we're not really sure if
he is dead or alive at the moment but
let's hope that he makes an appearance
in the next Thor movie so that's it for
each individual poster and like I said
one thing that I found kind of peculiar
is some of the characters that they
chose to make posters of characters like
Korg and Heimdall and Valkyrie I hope
this is a way of them saying these
characters are important and they're
going to continue to be important going
forward in future MCU movies we're not
really sure what the future holds for
the MCU but what we do know is that
these past 10 years have been amazing
and I'm sure that they're gonna do
everything that they can to make the
next 10 years even more amazing
we're still gonna have our same beloved
heroes and characters and the mantle of
some may be passed down to other
characters but still we're going to
continue to get great heroes and great
movies so that's it for this video on
all the posters I hope you enjoyed it
and I want to know what your favorite
poster was let me know in the comments
below as always if you enjoyed this
video please give it a thumbs up and of
course subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on a vendor's for Marvel DC
and all things superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]